[Música]
colores brillantes y ambiente festivo el
desfile del orgullo volvió a las calles
de Washington DC mientras Estados Unidos
celebra el mes del orgullo la capital
del país recibió el sábado con los
brazos abiertos a la comunidad lgbtqi
más de toda la costa este sede de una de
las mayores comunidades diplomáticas del
mundo hasta las embajadas se retaron al
ritmo de músicas de todo el mundo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
es un día de diversión pero la lucha por
la igualdad de derechos sigue siendo la
prioridad
en Estados Unidos se nos cuestiona
constantemente hay gente que no cree que
seamos importantes pero al fin y al cabo
lo que importa es que nos den nuestros
derechos humanos y nos dejan ser
nosotros Eso es todo lo que pido Ni más
ni menos
al margen de la marcha esta pareja de
Florida es muy consciente de las
amenazas que pesan sobre los derechos de
las personas homosexuales en Estados
Unidos
es nuestro gobernador y ha creado un
proyecto de ley llamado No digas gay y
esencialmente Está tratando de censurar
cualquier conversación en torno a ser
gay
bien que estar en la comunidad lgbtq y
es una preocupación real que va a quitar
algunos de los derechos que ahora tienen
los legisladores estatales han
presentado más de 400 proyectos de ley
contra la comunidad lgbtqi más desde
principios de año ahora que los votantes
estadounidenses empiezan a centrar su
atención en las primarias demócratas y
republicanas ya está claro que los
derechos lgbtqi más serán uno de los
temas centrales de las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024